hey youtubers is Charlie so everybody
was asking me to do a Shazam Black Adam
video it's still going to be one of the
big Justice League films Warner Brothers
confirmed in the last day that they are
still working on it
The Rock is still attached to be Black
Adam so there's just a breakdown of
what's going on with that will they
announce that it is connected to the
larger DC Universe if you guys didn't
know that before yeah I mean you kind of
have to assume fit all DC movies that
are being made now are inside this DC
Universe but some of them will be more
connected than the others like think of
the core Justice League members that
we've already met those films were
incredibly closely linked even Suicide
Squad but thus far Suicide Squad has
been the only introduction to magic in
the DC Universe and it's very
supernatural kind of magic but they've
been using the blanket term for anybody
with any kind of powers no matter where
they got their powers no matter how they
work they've been calling them all
metahumans so even though it sounds kind
of weird they do call Superman a
metahuman in Suicide Squad
so Billy Batson who becomes Shazam black
Adam anybody from that area of the
comics would also be considered a
metahuman according to Amanda Waller and
the government but a lot of you might
remember a couple years ago when they
were just like getting things rolling
with Batman V Superman they announced
that they signed the rock as Black Adam
in the Shazam movie and they'd begun
development so cut to a couple years
later and it's like ok so it's been a
couple years but we haven't heard
anything is the movie dead what's
happening they said they're still
developing it with the rock but they
haven't really anounced a release date
let's say that it's more real the movie
is more real than the Marvel Inhumans
movie because Kevin Feige took it off
the Marvel schedule but he's like we're
still working on it it's still happening
but it's not on the schedule so it's
like well how much is it happening so
you have to take it with a grain of salt
so Inhumans movie at Marvel is happening
Shazam movie is happening at DC just to
be determined in terms of release date
and they have not cast their billy
batson yet that's the next most
important thing because I think a lot of
people don't realize there's really like
three important characters that they
need to cast for the movie and they've
already cast Black Adam he's one he's
the big villain he'll be a lot of fun he
very much looks the part but they need
to cast the young Billy Batson who's
like a 10 year old kid then they need to
cast his adult self
we'll be the one walking around as
Shazam when Billy Batson says his power
word so it sounds like they're looking
for the right story and then waiting for
the right kid to come along so just
consider it the same way you would
consider the Booster Gold movie there's
a Booster Gold movie that they're making
it'll be part of the DC Universe but
it's it's kind of like a comedy type
film so it's not a perfect fit with the
other movies that they made so far but
it's scheduled for 2018 release date
that might get pushed a little bit
depending on how development continues
but there is a person who is working on
the script in fact the person that is
writing the Booster Gold movie is
actually one of the writers for the
flash TV show who is developing it with
Greg Berlanti so that's a whole other
thing if you have absolutely no idea who
this is am character is he's Billy
Batson and this is where it gets a lot
of fun they could have a lot of fun with
the way they weave the character in with
the Justice League in the future so
Billy Batson stumbles upon the wizard
Shazam and the rock of eternity who's
kind of like the guardian of all magic
on earth so he imbues Billy Batson with
this power to do good so he has the
ability to call down the power of a
bunch of different gods you know kind of
based on the Greek pantheon so like he
has the speed of Hermes so he can be as
fast as the flash he has magical
lightning like Zeus he can fly he has a
number of different powers that he can
use each at any given time but he has to
like specifically call down those powers
but they're activated when he says his
power word the word is Shazam so he says
she's AM boom struck by the magical
lightning and what it does is it
transforms him into his ideal self and
his ideal self is an adult so when he's
walking around as Shazam he looks like
he would if he were an adult but he's
like a ten year old kid walking around
in the body of his adult self so the fun
part is is that his adult self looks
very similar to Clark Kent Superman so I
think it'd be really fun for the movie
to play with the idea that Superman is
like the god of earth everybody either
worships him or hates him and thinks
he's a demon so Billy Batson
ten-year-old kid like a typical
ten-year-old kid would probably
idealizes Superman and wants to be like
him so when he activates the power of
Shazam wouldn't it be awesome if he
looked a little bit like Superman in the
movie now obviously they can't have
Henry Cavill play Shazam
make the metaphor that literal but it
can be someone who looks relatively like
Henry Cavill so it's like oh of course a
ten-year-old kid in this universe would
probably love the idea of Superman and
think that he's the best thing ever
wouldn't your ideal self look kind of
like Superman so let me know in the
comments how do you think they're going
to connect the Shazam movie to the
Justice League movie because they've
already done supernatural things because
of Suicide Squad so it's not super hard
to connect them but there has to be a
reason for Billy Batson to work with the
Justice League so that means that the
rock Black Adam in the movie will have
to do something that's so big and
terrible that it will get the attention
of Batman and the Justice League like oh
my god what is happening in this part of
the world there's this giant magical
battle like Batman we'll have to see
Billy Batson as Shazam take Black Adam
down and be like okay he was also
inspired by a Superman sacrifice so we
should probably get him on our team
before something terrible happens to him
because remember Amanda Waller's comment
during Suicide Squad she said we need to
get these metahumans on our team before
somebody else picks them up as if the
other governments of the world like the
not-so-nice governments of the world and
other evil organizations are trying to
build their own teams of metahumans so I
think what will happen is is that you
know whatever goes that whatever the
plot they want to use for the Shazam
movie is going to be it'll just get the
attention of the Justice League
I think Superman would actually be a
good cameo in that film - like you have
Batman cameo and some of the other films
Superman should cameo and some of the
other films too but I think he works
better in films of more powerful people
like he would work really well in the
Aquaman movie Shazam is another one -
because Shazam is kind of like the
Superman of magic any kind of looks like
him - in the comics so let me know do
you think that this Shazam actor like
the person as the adult Shazam should
look kind of like Henry cavils version
of Superman so hopefully they'll have a
little bit of fun with that but if there
was any confusion Shazam movie still
happening will totally connect to
Justice League but as announced in my
Aquaman video that I just posted I was
going to do a Supergirl video but
there's a new round of the giveaway that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card so next video will be that
Supergirl season 2 video and then I'll
probably do some Marvel after that it's
been a little while since I've done a
Marvel video
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my Aquaman video and
you can click here to learn all about
Superman Supergirl season 2 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you